My husband hasn't been home in a few days,
but he's gonna be home in about four hours,
so I decided to surprise him with a variation of one of his favorite
desserts, which are cinnamon rolls.
I had a bunch of raspberries at home,
so I decided to make some raspberry lemon rolls.
Started with my dough by combining some milk, sugar,
butter, eggs,
and then gradually adding in my flour.
I made sure to mix it very well until it was all combined
before pouring it out onto my counter and starting to knead it.
I needed it for about eight to 10 minutes
until it was all smooth and came together
before placing it in a bowl to rise.
After about two hours, it had doubled in size,
so I released all the air and then started on my filling.
Kept this very simple with some brown sugar,
cornstarch, and some frozen raspberries.
Gave that a mix before sprinkling that all over my dough.
I tried to get it as even as possible
and then rolled it up and sliced it into equal pieces.
I buttered my baking tray and placed my rolls inside,
making sure that they weren't too close to each other,
before covering them in cling film
and letting them rise for another hour and a half.
At this point, I preheated my oven
and placed some more raspberries on top of my rolls
before popping them in the oven for about 30 minutes.
Bake them until they were golden brown and let them cool
while I started on my frosting
with some cream cheese, milk,
powdered sugar, lemon zest,
vanilla, and a squeeze of lemon juice.
I mixed that all up and then spread that on top of my rolls.
30 minutes later, lucky walked through the door,
so it was perfect timing. I plated him one,
and he absolutely loved it.